why is writing TV better than Writing
Movies
television is the place for Innovation
now it's the most exciting area for
people who want to create originally I
know that's in contradiction to the
tradition where people thought well
Independent films was me expressing my
voice and my idea actually television
has so much opportunity now that there
are many many ways to tell your story or
to tell any story and I think just the
plethora of opportunity is part of what
makes it great the other thing that
makes it great is that you can do the
long narrative that in writing a movie
if it's a two-hour movie your story
really has to end in 90 minutes or 120
Minutes or even if it's a little bit
flexible from that with television you
can tell a six hour story an eight-hour
story a 13-hour story a 26 hour story or
a story that lasts a hundred hours and
that means that you can expand
vertically by that what I mean is not
that the plot goes on and on but that
the depth of character is something that
you can continue to reveal and secrets
keep coming out over the many many hours
of a show and it's a different kind of
creating it's a little bit more like
life in the sense that life doesn't end
in two hours or it doesn't end when a
plot comes to the point that something
concludes or finishes it's it's the
continuity of experience and all of that
is some of what television offers now
and then I guess the the only downside
would be that you would have to test
your story to make sure that it does
have legs to be more than 90 minutes
well in creating a show uh a an episodic
television show as opposed to for
example a movie movie for television or
even a limited series
um in doing a longer
series what you need to do is conceive
of it at the beginning to make sure that
it has legs and springboards and by that
I mean that the story uh has a potential
to continue having generating other
stories as it goes along mostly
propelled by the the characters in the
cast
springboards also means that uh each
episode whether it's an hour or a half
hour or whatever length it is needs
something that Springs It Forward
whereas in a movie you might have you
know a continuous plot that starts with
you know whatever the inciting moment is
at the beginning has a certain number of
plot points or changes and comes to a
conclusion and that's really too simple
for what television is so the the
complexity is something you bring to it
from the very very start it's not
something you find later
how is writing a television show
different from writing a movie
writing for television is uh faster
and more specific in terms of getting
the uh internal motor going for the
characters uh the process if you're on
an actual show
does have to do with deadlines you have
to write fast enough that if you are
doing multiple episodes of a show that
you're on schedule so the idea of the
artist in the Garrett waiting for a muse
to strike is not going to work if you're
writing for television you really have
to turn out the work
I find that that's actually energizing
to the creative process rather than
deadening I think the idea that somebody
is waiting for what you have and that
there's a lit just that little bit of
pressure on you to deliver sometimes
helps you actually get to work and to
pull out what you need to do writing for
movies
I don't know how much this industry even
exists anymore there are two ways that
people write for movies now one is that
you're on a blockbuster franchise and
that's
I that's writing but it's writing to a
formula that is somebody else's and it
is also uh means you're part of a team
which is essentially director and
producer driven or sometimes even star
driven so that your uh
the chance for you to exercise your
creativity is uh
is within those parameters I wouldn't
say it's gone it's never gone you can
always give whatever you can and bring
whatever you can to the story and the
characters but I find that to me that's
limiting the other kind of writing for
for movies or theatrical features uh is
the Indie process the Indie process is
not a business the Indie process means
you need to finance your own material
and you go to the art festivals the end
product of doing indie films is that you
might get hired to work on television
because there is not much business there
in other words how many people are going
to see some small indie film unless you
can get it on Netflix because now the
boundary between what is a movie and
what is television is is certainly
graying if not eroding completely almost
all of the premium outlets are doing uh
what I call the shorter form which is
the two-hour form or even 90 minute form
uh as well as much longer in fact things
are in all sorts of sizes now you can
get uh a half hour you can get an hour
you can get two hours you could get uh
more rarely three hours or four hours
but they happen six hours for a limited
series uh eight hours is common for an
entire season 13 12 and 13 is common for
an entire season there are no more 22
hour Seasons really
and then it goes on to the next year so
you might easily get 36 hours of
Storytelling on television in a movie
you have the time that you might need to
do your work if you want to spend three
months or six months or two years
writing one film uh you can do that
because it's your own unless you're
being hired in other words if you're
just doing your own personal movie
uh if you're being hired you're back on
your schedule again and uh the next
episode of you know Batman or Spider-Man
if you're so lucky to get on those big
franchises uh is due at a certain date
so it sounds like then really the only
way that artists can sort of be their
own driver and sort of work as you said
in this Garrett waiting to be discovered
is an art house type film because uh
television or or tentpole movies it's a
it's a collab it's a it's a bike
Committee in a sense uh no actually
um yes if you want to do art house films
anybody can do that you're in the
fundraising business if you do that you
must understand that uh
it is in a sense less free because so
much of your time is spent raising money
and then marketing
um but no I think that the most
artistically creative thing you could do
is an original television series uh or
even a certain series that are may not
be yours but that give you a great deal
of freedom in terms of uh evolving the
characters and the story lines if you
look at something like Atlanta Donnie
Glover's show
or or you look at something like
handmaid's tale which is of course based
on a book or any number of other things
Orange is the New Black uh the list is
long
there is very little in the theatrical
feature Arena that is as incisive and
challenging and original as some of the
work on those shows so uh to me you know
this is just my own bias I know there
are people who feel differently my own
bias is that for originality creativity
and uh exploration you really can't beat
what's happening on television now in
all of its forms if you increase it to
really all of the forms
but one maybe should test themselves how
well do they work in groups
oh I mean yes yes if you're on the staff
of a show
if you're on a staff
it is collaborative that's true if
you're so fortunate as to be in a
writer's room
uh you will be around a table all day
every day with uh four or five or seven
or ten or however many you have fellow
writers and producers
creating material you then go off and do
your owner individual episode and bring
that back to the room so in that sense
it's a little bit like a writer's
Workshop where
yeah you get the general structure of
what you're supposed to do for that
episode in the group you go do it when
it comes back you're going to get notes
from collaborators uh
you hope and in the best shows this is
true
that these collaborators are all
building together to make your episode
shine
so there should be
ideally no sense of competition or you
know tearing anybody down it's all a
matter of in service to the best
possible work and in service to the show
and ultimately yes the showrunner's
vision uh
but not everything is is like that if
you look at the uh work at Phoebe Waller
Bridge uh whether that's killing Eve or
a fleabag or other things she's done uh
for the woman's point of view uh coming
alive on screen I can't think of much
anything anywhere that delivers that
quite as well as she has done with her
television series well if you look at
something like Breaking Bad or or Better
Call Saul Vince Gilligan's uh worlds
that he has created are so character
rich
that it doesn't even matter if these
guys are drug pushers or criminal
lawyers or whatever we love them we're
rooting for them and that's that is such
a strength uh and it comes from the
writer
how fast do you have to write a
television script versus a movie script
generally if you're on the staff of a
show
from the time that your outline is
locked no we're talking about a process
until you get that outline done so
there's been a pitch there's been a
story discussion there's been a
structuring there's been an outline
there's been a revised outline so
starting from that moment which is at
that point weeks in
you might have two weeks or three weeks
to write a script depending on the show
that's the traditional rhythm but there
are shows that package up entirely
before they ever shoot and if they're
going to do it a whole season in advance
you might have more time a movie script
if it's if you're doing it on your own
take the rest of your life if you want I
mean who cares
um but again if you're working for a
producer who has commissioned it you
will have a deadline the deadline might
be depending on the nature of it you
might have a month or two
uh but I find that students especially
writing first scripts need much longer
my students who write scripts at USC
might take an entire semester of four
months to finish a draft and then
another semester of another three or
four months to polish that draft that's
luxurious and it's because they're
students and they're getting feedback
if you work at that pace in the industry
I think they'd be considered very slow
and is that something that your students
are very aware of that it is actually
you're giving them more time than maybe
they would have how they be yeah no they
know uh they know and they're um
you can tell them but that's different
it's one thing to be told is another
thing to be in in the midst of the world
where somebody says okay go home I want
to see our first draft in two weeks
and you know are they going to panic
they shouldn't Panic if they have if
they have the tools that they've been
given you can you can easily do an hour
and two weeks
um my when I was doing those kinds of
things my Pace was always that I would
uh
if you think of an hour as being maybe
28 scenes maybe less depends
um and if you think about it if you
write two scenes per day
and that's not very much really that's
you know
Maybe
four to six pages per day it's all
you're writing but if you do that
for two for 14 days at just at just even
two scenes per day
you've got your 28 scenes in two weeks
and you could do it faster so it's not a
it's not a burdensome schedule really at
all
how does a writer decide if their story
will be more effective as a film or a
television series
all stories that mean
something to audiences
are based on human beings
there is no storytelling that is not
character driven so the special effects
approach uh whether that's superheroes
or fantasy action adventure uh
might be fun for a big screen
and the audience which tends to be uh
adolescent boys
um
and if what you want to write
is uh special effects Laden
fantasy action adventure uh or any other
kind of
um
big action Panorama you're much better
off with the movie
if that's what you want to do
but if what you
want to write our stories involving
human beings and their relationships and
their issues whether that's personal or
political or whatever it is or
historical or contemporary
if it's based from character uh
I don't think you're going to find
a lot of takers in the movie industry uh
on the studio level because what used to
be small films or personal films or or
dramas character dramas are not easy to
finance because they don't know how
they're going to make their money back
unless of course maybe you have a big
star involved but even in that case
the star world is no longer what it used
to be there aren't movie stars that can
drive box office like they used to be
so I really think that um
if if the question is deciding which to
write for it's what is it that you want
to write
so you don't think that there's a modern
day carry Grant I mean we just watched
them no I don't I mean there are names
that you would know I mean Tom Cruise is
currently uh
being called the last movie star because
he's trying to you know reboot his you
know his flying movie Top Gun from the
1980s I guess 1980s it was yeah uh more
than 30 about 30 years ago or so
um we'll come see him now because
they're recapturing their youth I don't
know how many of those people are going
to the movies honestly
um if you look at somebody like Zendaya
which is uh from Euphoria on HBO now she
has a following now she had a following
first as a musician before she did as an
actress and then Euphoria is capturing a
certain feeling about high school life
which is not not accurate and I have my
own ideas about like Euphoria but unless
it is very successful and she is a star
but she's a star that did not ever work
in movies
uh she's a television star and a big
star and a bigger star than many of the
other names you might see out there
there are wonderful people who are still
around Jane Fonda for example and Lily
Tomlin doing that wonderful uh Grace and
Frankie best television
sure sure and that was based off a movie
wasn't it was there under the origin of
it but yeah a lot of things that are on
television are based on books or on
International materials
has film versus television evolved
further from each other
as time has gone on let's say it's how
the popularity of streaming has emerged
and then the cinema experience for
whatever reason has maybe gone away
the cinema experience has certainly
changed with the closure of theaters
that's partly pandemic related
and it's partly Financial
and it's partly that why go spend that
much money for the tickets and the
parking and the dinner and the
babysitter if that's something that you
know happens to you
when you could wait a few weeks and
it'll be on Netflix or Amazon or
something else
so I think that the I noticed that
nearby The Landmark Theater just closed
in in the West Side Pavilion so
exhibition theaters are really getting
to be more like
theaters for plays where there's special
events
uh or or theaters for concerts special
events where you know you're going out
for the night and you're spending a lot
of money because it is an experience uh
on the other hand uh the opportunities
for exhibition on television have
increased of movies
so in that sense they're coming together
the only thing is there is a difference
of the viewing experience between
something in a dark theater on a large
screen and something on your home screen
or even your computer screen
televisions and homes in terms of
convergence many theater screens got
smaller for a while so that you could
have you know smaller theaters in
multiplexes at the same time as
television home television screens got
bigger so they're almost the same size
almost the same experience that's
changing a bit now as the small screen
multiplexes are going away they're just
not a
a much of a business model
and more and more people are watching on
their computers
even on their phones if you're watching
something whether it's a movie or a
television show on your phone it's a
very different experience because
the kind of information you're getting
on a screen that size is different and
it tends to complement
the experience of intimacy with a
character and be not good for panoramic
storytelling
although I have to say personally
nothing beats like a Sunday matinee with
maybe three people in the theater that's
wonderful but imagine from the uh the
theater owner's point I understand those
three people are not paying his rent I
know in fact probably a drain on their
or probably a negative uh well the
closing for that reason yeah it's a it
may be luxurious in the same sense as
any private screening is luxurious uh if
you talk to the theater Owners
Association they'll they're all in woe
sure yeah hopefully though some somehow
we figure out a way or it becomes
fashionable again in some sense well I
well it will always be there as an
experience in the same sense as going to
the theater going to a concert
but that puts uh the pressure on uh
showing blockbusters
or special events of some sort and it
makes it even harder on the small
independent personal film
which will have
you know very very little in the way of
an audience so uh so those films will do
fine on television because actually uh
if you're dealing with the small
personal indie film that tends to be
character driven anyway well that's what
television is
and there's no reason that people can't
uh tune in for something that is just 90
minutes long and they do
your book right here this is something
that's required reading for some of your
students oh
it is required reading throughout the
industry I sometimes go into
offices and I find this on executive
desks and sometimes I've heard that the
mentorship programs for developing new
writers on on television are requiring
this for the mentees coming in and yes
my students all read this at USC it's
it's kind of the Bible of the industry
for how to write for television and this
is the fourth edition
the reason it's the fourth edition is
that television keeps growing and
changing the very first edition of this
book came out in 2000
five I think and you can imagine how
different the world was that was before
streaming and it was out of date on
publication uh
and I've every few years I do another
version this is the end of 2018 and
after this more has happened so this
book has everything in it
great yeah so so when you were writing
it I guess Netflix was mailing out DVDs
no uh 2018 uh it was after that oh oh
I'm in the for I'm sorry I should oh
earlier one no and Netflix wasn't even
mailing them out at the time the only
thing in 2005 uh there was still the the
four Legacy networks is all plus HBO
and HBO had only been in business you
know four or five years AMC was doing
some very interesting things uh but
Breaking Bad hadn't yet come on and uh
every everything changed after that
everything changed there was a four act
structure required in 2005 of everything
and that has changed so the world has
moved on uh in a in fascinating ways
you say that once streaming hit it
changed everything streaming changed
everything because it allowed people uh
to make more choices it also allowed
more production it also broadened the
idea of the structure of Television
because uh way back in the earlier 2000s
and before that everything was in a four
act structure on television because it
had to allow for advertising every 13
minutes or so so you would divide your
60 minutes into roughly four acts
roughly four 15-minute segments they
weren't really exactly 15 minutes but
something like that it so that there
could be a commercial break at the end
of each one
and then there was a teaser
generally this traditional traditional
structure which I'll tell you is a
teaser
uh well let me start that again the
traditional structure was the uh Show's
title with even a theme song
then sometimes there was
a small commercial even right away
and then there's the teaser
anywhere from 30 seconds to five minutes
which uh literally teases the action or
sometimes in a procedural would give you
the crime or the case to be solved
then they'd be a commercial then you'd
go into act one which would go to
roughly
18 20 minutes 18 20 Pages then they'd be
a commercial act two would go to roughly
30-ish pages
traditional at break
uh act three which is the
worst case the climactic
encounter would go to roughly page 45
ish
and then at four would go to the end and
would be slightly shorter would probably
be 57 58 or 55 minutes and then there'd
be another act break uh and another uh
commercial
then it got longer and in uh 2006 uh ABC
decided that they wanted to go to Six
acts in order to stick stick in more
commercials
uh and so you ended up with a very long
act one
so the people wouldn't lose you and then
they break X6 into uh at four into
four and five and then there would be a
tag after the final Act which sometimes
led into the next week
um
and they would get more commercials in
and this just got worse and worse and
worse and worse uh where there were uh
some shows on traditional networks that
had almost more commercial material than
dramatic material uh and people got fed
up uh
one of the things about streaming is
that there were no commercials
the minute there were no commercials you
no longer had not only did you no longer
have that structure but you had actually
more air time
you had more flexibility of telling
stories now HBO always had no
commercials and the same was true of
Showtime
now you can get AMC with or without
commercials but I watched Better Call
Saul the other day as it's as it ran on
television as opposed to seeing it
streaming and I was appalled that this
wonderful storytelling kept being
interrupted by trying to sell me
something
and I the same thing's true of Hulu
where you could buy it with or without
commercials you just pay more if you
don't have the commercials I can't
imagine watching handmaid's tale uh you
know Disturbed every several minutes by
selling me something and I just don't I
just won't watch anything that way if I
can avoid it so that's part of the big
change it changed structurally but it
also changed the kind of material and it
changed the way people watched and the
and the number of choices people could
make
and I'm sure that encourages binge
viewing if there's no commercials
because you're so set in the story well
you can also continue because you know
and they know they they the purveyors of
these absolutely know that I think
Amazon does this that after you finish
an episode there's a little ticker thing
that says next episode starts in five
four three two one like no I'm not I
don't want to watch I sat here long
enough uh
but it's very easy to be glued for a
very long time and by the way this
disabuses the notion that young
audiences have shut such short times
such short attention spans that they
will only watch something that's three
minutes or 10 minutes long it was
discovered because it was tried on
YouTube
what would happen if we gave people the
option of watching 10-minute acts that
is 10-minute segments or and have 12 of
them to make a 120 minute movie
or
to let them look at all 10 one after
another after another after another
everybody watched all 10. uh so it's
just not true uh it has to do with
interest and attention it doesn't have
to do with something's wrong with the
brain of of young people who can't pay
attention for more than a few minutes if
they're interested enough they're there
sure and I mean if you have your morning
coffee I'm speaking more for myself I'm
going to be more add and switch around
than if it's later in the day and I'm
tired and now I don't have anything more
on my plate my attention is going to be
there so yeah well one of the things
about streaming is you can watch it at
any time I mean if if you're a morning
viewer you could see something that
would normally have been an evening show
at any time in the day
years ago when West Wing and er were on
and they always started at 10 pm
I knew I was going to be watching from
10 to 11 at night
I would rather not watch from 10 to 11
at night and I would rather see those
same shows at nine or any other time and
now I can
one last thing you'd set the tag forgive
me what is the tag oh a a uh in terms of
structure after you get to your final
Act
in some shows uh not all of them there's
a form where there's an act break or a
break of some sort and then there's more
dramatic material
and that extra dramatic material is
usually quite short it might be one
scene or two scenes maybe three scenes
but not really much longer and either it
does something as a commentary on what
that episode was about and twists it or
it just simply starts introducing what's
going to be on the next episode uh every
show is different you don't find this
sort of thing very much on on streaming
and so this we're really when we talk
about act breaks and the four or five or
six Acts or the number of Acts plus the
teaser and a tag we're really we're
really dealing with traditional Legacy
television
can you tell us about the four act Grid
in my book here there is an extensive
conversation about maybe I could find a
page here somewhere yeah here's a
picture of it and I it says using the
grid and I find and here is the non-grid
uh analyzing structure from a different
point of view
all right there's some other things you
can find it in the book
um
I found that even after the traditional
Forex structure was abandoned by
Networks that as I talk to people who
are writing for Netflix or HBO or any
other form at all Amazon uh when I talk
to seasoned writers they were all still
using it and just dropping out the ACT
break
and the reason they were using it is
that it works it works as a storytelling
mechanism even if it does not need to be
something that accommodates advertising
and that was very interesting that given
the option to not use it
plenty of people figured out gee I need
a form anyway and you don't just start
on page one and go to page 60 or
whatever you know in a row without
having any idea uh where the where the
changes are where the emphasis are where
the energy goes this way or that way
what about Cliffhangers and it was
discovered by a number of of seasoned
writers that you know what I can go back
to the tools that I always used without
ever having calling it a break or having
an ad and what it has to do with the
rhythm of experience
that there is a something by I think
there may be something biological in the
roughly 15-minute span if you go to a
movie
in a theater of which there aren't very
many anymore but if you were to go in a
movie
in a successful movie in a theater and
You observe you'd note you might notice
that roughly every 13 or to 15 minutes a
little around the audience squirms
and I've observed this several times and
I think it is actually biological I
think people are looking for a change of
pace they're looking for a cliffhanger
they're looking for
something that turns the action in
another Direction in what uh some people
have called a plot point though you
don't need to use that terminology and
uh I think there is something to rid the
rhythm of writing uh
in fact if you look at the traditional
three-act structure this the old Sid
Fields three extractor which wasn't
invented by Sid Fields it predates him
by a long time but anyway
um
that structure said that act 1 act 1 was
one quarter of the time at two is two
quarters of the time half
and act three is one quarter of the time
and that's how the three acts work
they're not three even acts the second
act is double
but if you draw a median line down the
middle of that second act
which is often where the uh
mid-story character comes in and where
there's a big change you're back you've
got four acts and so you're still back
to the same thing now it plays out
differently in a hundred minutes than it
would in 60 minutes but not that
differently
um
and so people experiment with what
Netflix will tell you and what HBO will
tell you uh is don't talk to me about
act breaks uh
write what the story needs
write it whatever length the story needs
to be and we'll deal with it
and I think that's wonderful as a very
generous way of approaching writers the
writer still has to go home and
structure the story
so what the story needs to be still
needs turns still needs anticipation
still needs what used to be called plot
points still needs a motor
that drives to certain kinds of flips
and and still needs some sort of
resolution so you find yourself back
with some of the most traditional uh
lessons in how to write as you write for
even the most advanced television
so for the outlining process if we were
to tell someone don't worry about plot
structure that could throw it off it
sounds like this is very necessary no I
I make my students write very very
structured outlines
they can
um I never say don't don't worry about
plot structure I ask them what is your
story and where are the turns and twists
and when do they occur and they'd better
know that before they start washing
around in a script that's an unknown
length going in unknown directions so no
that doesn't happen I I believe in a in
what I was taught which was that you get
a locked out line that you get a really
good outline and if you are outlined
tells the story well as driven by the
characters and has enough Cliffhangers
and twists and surprises and
anticipation your script will be easy to
write if you're if you're sweating your
script it's because there was something
wrong with the outline
that'll get a lot of comments because
there's two you know of course you know
there's people very resistant to it
nobody likes to write outlines outlines
are uh
you know I with my students I tell them
when the outlines are done you're out of
outline jail because they're no fun they
don't give you a chance to show off your
ability of dialogue or description
they're not beautiful they're
engineering and creative people might
want to resist oh no you're going to you
know make it too rigid actually it's
freeing it's freeing if you know where
you're going you can go there very well
if you're lost you have a hard time
making anything work out
what are the different structures for
television
television usually exists as half hours
and limited series
within that
there's some flexibility the half hour
form which used to be limited to sitcoms
and really isn't anymore
um
really only runs 20 22 minutes it's very
short
but how is that divided well
some people used to say the comedy
structure was uh
you know three beats up three beats down
with a whoops in the middle
I don't think that holds any more there
are comedies that are in three-act
structure standard three extractor
they're comedies that are in Forex
structure there are comedies that are
what the heck is going on here and
um
and they can all work because they're
propelled by the characters and the kind
of material and the kind of humor if
there is humor half hours are also not
only comedy uh more half hours are
dramedy now or what you might call as uh
simply half hour dramas and that's
different also if you look at something
like Atlanta
which is not bound by
Legacy structure that it has to fit
within a half hour plus ads which brings
it down to like a 20-minute show you
might have a 40-minute episode
and HBO is perfectly happy to have that
happen
upcoming away from Comedy which is not
my specialty uh ours are
depends where you where you look an hour
might be more than an hour
on on HBO
or might be a full hour and even a
little more on HBO or Netflix or even
Amazon
um
it might be much less than it might be
on Legacy television it's 40 some odd
minutes
because they're allowing for the
commercials so it varies and then the
limited series uh are all different if
you look at something like
um David devane's uh when you see us
that's uh six hours
uh brilliant six hours most of those
hours are one hour long but sometimes I
think one of them if I recall the
beginning one was two hours long
um and you often see that in the uh
in the um
I don't want to say miniseries in the
limited series you'll also often find
that one of those hours is a two-hour
segment
uh they call it special it's also called
as you know finishing the show
um
but are they an hour long
financially kinda mostly kind of they
have to fit on the schedule
um Game of Thrones was often not an hour
it was more
uh
a handmaid's tale is less
because on Hulu it shows with
commercials
so if you're if you're working on a show
you have to look at that show and see
how they work
and then Better Call Saul yeah AMC and
AMC has commercials and uh
it could certainly it certainly has the
depth uh to go for an hour but it
doesn't it runs more like 50 minutes
what's the difference between a five act
and a six-act structure well I first of
all don't really believe in Acts
structures so much anymore I I really
like to look at the Forex structure as a
basis and the 5x structure is a Forex
structure with the fourth act divided in
half a sixth acts
sometimes is those BuyBacks and then you
add a tag which is some extra material
but there's also another way of doing it
which is that every Act is a little
shorter
I don't
I don't recommend anybody writing a spec
episode in six Acts
I really think that if somebody out
there is watching this in order to learn
how to write a sample a spec sample
script which is required by many of the
fellowships that you should really go
with the four act plus teaser or no acts
at all
the six act structure is Clumsy because
it keeps breaking first of all and then
also the reader anticipates it's going
to be ending and then oh wait a minute
here's another piece
so I I don't think anybody should do
that and so for a first-time spec writer
uh submitting something should they
stick to an hour
Well yeah if they're doing drama they
have to stick to another they have to
okay I mean if you're a comedy writer
that's different
uh then uh clearly you will write a
comedy uh sample
and that's that's another world
altogether it's if it's uh
if it's
taped I mean if it's multicam not too
many people are doing that anymore
but if it's a multicam sitcom in the
old-fashioned sense it's probably going
to be uh
in a different page format as well you
have to look you'll look that up whereas
dramatic scripts and uh live action
filmed comedies look like feature films
can you explain a b and c stories
a b and c stories are parallel stories
that are not subplots
in dramatic shows especially
you will have major full plots that are
linked to
primary characters
uh the a story generally has more beats
the B story may have the same number
beats or fewer and the C story is
sometimes a runner it's just a way of
thinking about storytelling uh when you
have
the kinds of narrative that lap over
from episode to episode so you might
have an a story in episode five which is
actually continues in episode six as a b
story and comes back to being an a story
in episode seven and you might have it
weaving so the B story which is also
very important but not the prominent one
in episode five really has a major turn
in episode six so you're you're weaving
throughout the season as well as weaving
within your episode that isn't to say
the episode can't stand alone because it
should but
um
that's that's what parallel storytelling
is it's just multiple narratives they
are not subplots to each other they are
full stories
could we try using that with an example
of something maybe Better Call Saul uh
Better Call Saul might have Jimmy Saul
um as the a story uh Kim his wife
might have a separate Arc in that show
even though she also intersects with him
but there also might be a story for
nacho
which doesn't even include Saul or Kim
and takes place at a different it's
takes place in Mexico is in a different
place a different time uh well at the
same time usually but a different
location with different characters
they all Impact each other and there's
usually a thematic link but they're
actually separate stories in themselves
if you look at the precursor Breaking
Bad Walter White
will have a story uh
would Jesse have a separate story with
different characters maybe maybe
um Walters
in Breaking Bad Walter White really was
the dominant person but there were there
there are other characters who might
have scenes that he isn't in
and might have a number of Beats that
tell whatever their Ark is to that show
how do you stretch out an idea over
multiple episodes without it feeling too
drawn out you never stretch an idea
there is no such thing as an idea that
stretches there's only a story that
needs to be told
if you find that your material is too
short that the story you have does not
last for an hour or for whatever length
of time you need to think about your
story and who these people are and what
more needs to be told never stretch and
never shrink
I've seen people I've seen students do
things that are just silly which is uh
to work with the final draft to make
more space between letters to make it
look bigger or take out space to make a
that doesn't fool anybody plus it won't
work because when you actually make the
show it's going to be what the length it
is so that's silly uh
if you find that you don't actually have
enough story
you can do a few things one is go back
into your characters and ask are there
layers of this character that I have not
yet examined
go back into your secondary characters
and say is there more to them are they
too superficial do they have arcs or
stories in themselves that could become
a b story uh is there a different place
to end my story am I if it's too short
uh have I stopped before it really
concluded or more likely have I failed
to develop the middle
uh generally people who are are lacking
material are lacking it in the middle
they think that lacking it at the end
and they need to go on
and that's never the that's rarely the
truth uh sometimes uh I have found
um early scripts that don't start in the
right place
the general notion is to start as close
to the action as possible so you want to
start as late as possible but there are
a number of instances where you really
need to know uh what led what caused
this story and they needed to back up
and add
essentially a whole Act
for what happened before or what
propelled the character so they were
missing something
never stretch never never fool with it
the idea and the story tells itself
so a better problem to have is how can I
condense this
into this you might say a better problem
is how to condense it if you need to hit
an hour if you need to hit 60 minutes
and if if it's running too long there
are a few things you can look at the
simplest is are your dialogue speeches
too long uh and that's a common error
that people are just simply over talking
that uh they say play it don't say it
you know there's something we can see
visually instead of explaining it uh or
that you've got Exposition that needs to
go because it's obvious anyway on screen
or because
um you have indulged in directing on the
page or set decoration so there's just
simply too much writing that isn't part
of telling the story so that's an
editing thing often editing won't um
if you're way long it it won't cut
enough pages I mean if you're up at uh
75 Pages for something that should be 60
Pages editing might not get you there uh
what may be happening in that case is
that uh you've actually strayed from the
focus of your story or that you even
have a whole other character or a whole
of a storyline that needs to be in a new
episode
so those those are things you can do if
you're running long
um
in gen or sometimes that your script was
really over and you went on
but you'd have to look at it Case by
case
there is unless you're Aaron Sorkin and
you're writing something that's normally
70 Pages because it's so dialogue Rich
that it's running it's six 70 Pages
they're going to run 60 minutes but
unless you're doing that and you
shouldn't be doing that
um
this is
you should get you should tighten your
script to what works within an hour
but if you're if you're first uh
inclination is how do I stretch this out
then you know that maybe go back to what
your your whole idea is even about
because it sounds like there needs to be
if your question is how do I stretch
this out you're asking the wrong
question
um
and you need to go all the way back to
who you are as a writer and what is the
thing you have to tell
does every writer need to know how to
write a pilot yes every writer needs to
write a pilot
um
first of all it's the coin of the realm
that people who people meaning agents
producers uh even people who are not in
the television business uh will read a
pilot before before they will read
anything else in a pilot they get the
originality of your voice and your
ability to tell the story and how to
write in a shorter amount of time than
having to slog through 120 pages of a
feature film so they get all of the same
advantage in a shorter reading time the
other thing is that a pilot is likely to
show a possible producer or fellowship
or agent
that you really understand in a compact
way how to deliver for today's audience
people watch television they are not
looking at movies so unless you are your
goal in life uh is to write episode 900
of some Blockbuster action fantasy
Adventure uh you really need to have a
pilot for an original show it doesn't
mean that show will be made it will not
be made but this is your showpiece this
is your Masterwork uh that will then get
you the chance to be on us on the staff
of a show at which point you can then
come back to your pilot and maybe then
it'll be made but absolutely pilot
writing is is the craft you need and I
would tell any beginning writer that
they should have more than one Pilot One
Pilot isn't enough for for one thing you
learn from every script you write and
you just get better and better uh the
other is that
um
you may find that after your first pilot
which you thought was the story you had
to tell that there's more to you than
that there are more stories to tell
generally shows that get bought are
built on underlying materials they're
built on books or or movies or other
other underlying
assets so the chance of selling your
pilot and getting it made her slight but
it's the thing without which you can't
work
so not just one pilot but several pilots
and expect them never to be made this is
your sort of calling card this is your
famous resume
that's right uh they might
I mean they might be made you can hope
they'll be made uh you never want to say
to yourself this will never be made but
they are evidence of craft they're
evidence of voice
they are who you are as a writer and uh
and who you are should not be one thing
I mean you can do more than one and you
should for one thing they'll get better
what questions should a writer be asking
themselves when they're about to embark
on a pilot
the question to not ask is how can I
imitate something that has already been
successful that's what to not do
uh I know sometimes people say well let
me game the business I saw this works
I'll do three percent of that and five
of that and you know here let me do all
this and yeah I got it and I'm going to
get rich and famous this doesn't work
um what really works is uh is the story
that only you can tell
and you whoever you are
knows that generally writers need to
write what hurts that doesn't mean
everything is tragic but it means you
are tapping into what you must say
because you have such a great need to
say it now that can be interpolated in a
way that's not personal you could do
that through history for example or even
through an imaginary character it
doesn't have to be you
but it needs to be something that you
need to convey emotionally and
psychologically
and if once you know what that is uh you
can see if there's a way to attach that
to something broader than just being
your purely personal intimate tale and
that can be as I say uh political social
historical uh it can be anything you'd
like it to be you can have music it can
have visual material it can have all
sorts of things but it really needs to
come from uh honesty and it's anybody
who reads a lot of scripts can tell
right away if something is dishonest
that is if something is just trying to
make a sale
and it's a turn off
what if somebody doesn't want to go
there and they say well I don't want if
if you don't want to do that you
shouldn't be a writer you know go do
some other job there are plenty of jobs
where you don't have to be introspective
or honest
in the world and there are plenty of
jobs even in the industry where you
don't have to be introspective or honest
uh
but if you want to be a writer there's a
reason you want to write it's because
there's something you want to write
about there's something you want to say
and I think that's your obligation to
the universe as and to yourself
how much of the world needs to be
created in the pilot
all of the world and all of the
characters are from the writer
you need to know everything nothing is
for the director to figure out later
now that doesn't mean you don't have uh
assets from the actors who will bring
depths and insight into the characters
that are beyond what you may have
imagined the director may also be able
to present a scene in a way that
amplifies some elements that you only
sketched in uh
the costumes might add something the
location can add wonderful things so
it's a collaborative field
but the writer is the first dreamer
among many dreams and there are uh
there's a basis in in knowing
what you are dealing with here and that
means creating the entire world by that
I don't mean specifics of the location
the Scout will do that but you need to
understand all of the energies which are
in this situation that you're that
you're going for
and there is no difference between
character and World there are characters
that could only exist in this situation
where they are and worlds that will be
different depending on the story look at
all the different medical shows that are
not the same medical show Gray's Anatomy
does not look like house and neither of
them looks like er
uh they're all medical shows but they
are different worlds because the world
comes from who the characters are
uh beyond that uh World building as an
exercise is really not something I would
uh suggest that writers spend a lot of
time dealing with I have seen people
make a mistake of going off into fantasy
worlds and you know decorating
characters with feathers and doing
things that can only be done with
animatronics and maybe that'll work on
some feature films I I think it's a
waste of time in television
sure I mean if we think back to the
original Blade Runner that world was so
unique right and even if you watch the
next Blade Runner it's still beautiful
worlds but there was something about
that original world that just it was
almost impossible to recreate well if
you look at Game of Thrones uh which has
seven worlds
actually seven locations very very
different uh films in different
countries whether you're in Northern
Ireland or whether you're in some
tropical place or a desert
there's absolutely uh unique and
important locations
and different sets of characters in each
world who Express the
sense of those worlds they are all
coalesced within a certain time frame a
certain time in life a sort of media
evilish time and a certain way that
people deal with each other so that was
definitely
an extreme case of World building but
again what made Game of Thrones the
great success it is well it's because we
really were caring about those
characters yeah they were great battle
scenes
and the worlds were gorgeous the
costumes were gorgeous
from George or George R.R Martin who
wrote the underlying novels uh the
imagining of the worlds were there from
the beginning so the writer had that
from minute one
and then it was just up to everybody
else to express that but no writers have
to have to do it all it this is your
world this is your character this is
your dream this is your story so
nothing's off the hook of oh well the
actor will do that or the director will
do that that's not the case you will do
that